Elton Elton 97.5 mumps me well I've got  something to tell you  Reggie we're gonna miss the bit of the  show with you on look shut up mom not on  tell you yet am i I'm talking to you  I mean John wick well the thing is I'm a  homosexual  a [ __ ] a fairy queen  you say something God's sake I know that  known for yes  you don't mind that I don't care but I'd  rather you keep that sort of thing to  yourself I just hope you realize you're  choosing a life of being alone forever  you'll never be loved properly  I don't never beloved thought if I put  me in this position again you don't  stage in 10 minutes so get over yourself  and do the show we're running a business  here you [ __ ] idiot  don't ever put your hands on me  [Music]